he is the author of one of the
best-selling business book series of all
time Rich Dad Poor Dad for the past
several years he's been a huge supporter
of the network marketing industry he's
made the claim that network marketing is
the business of the 21st century mentor
me Robert let me tell you why I endorsed
network marketing why I call it the
power of it the reason for it is as a as
an entrepreneur this word here network
marketing is the key to making a lot of
money
to being successful it's only those
people who have an employee mentality
working for a paycheck or like a
specialist or a small business guy who's
just wants it for themselves they don't
understand the power of network
marketing now let me give it this is not
just for the network marketing industry
you know when you talk about television
stations they talk about a television
network that's how big people think they
think in terms of networks when you talk
about radio they talk about a radio
network and the same thing my friend
owns a series of gas stations he calls
it a network of gas stations so the rich
used the term network a lot and I know
one of the reasons when I started in
endorsed network marketing is because in
many circles it has a negative
connotation and that's because a lot of
times people shouldn't be in the
business join the business or also
people abuse the business but the reason
I endorsed network marketing is for
people who really want to get out of the
rat race and really want to get on with
you know building a business by helping
other people build their businesses so
that's why I endorse network marketing
the other reason I endorse it is because
network marketing will give you the
sales skills or the communication skills
or the self esteem and the emotional
courage to go and knock on doors and
talk to other people if you don't have
that courage or you're more afraid of
what somebody else thinks of you you'll
probably never be successful at network
marketing but you'll probably never be
successful in business anyway so I love
network marketing because network
marketing will take an average per
like me or John and actually work with
you and build you up so you have the
personal courage to take the nose to
take the rejection to not really care
what I mean you do care but other people
think of you
it isn't people are not successful is
they want to follow the herd and do what
everybody else does and 90% of the
people on this earth when it comes to
money are financial losers so if you're
gonna become successful
you cannot care what the Thundering Herd
does you've really got to break away my
Rich Dad call it a 90/10 rule that meant
10% of the people make 90% of the money
and 90% of people make 10% of the money
so the beauty of network marketing
there's no guarantees but it gives you
the opportunity to be in that 10% and
the way you get in that 10% is to find
that person inside of you
who cares more of what you think about
yourself then you care what other people
think of you so the beauty of network
marketing is it gives people the courage
the sales skills and communication
skills to be a leader and that's what it
takes to be successful in world is to be
a leader as an entrepreneur I have built
many businesses from scratch and as
somebody who no one of them crashed also
statistics show that most new businesses
fail within the first five years 90% in
fact and of the 10% that survived the
remaining 10% crash in the second five
years so in other words most are gone in
ten years so I've looked at many
different models and one that stands out
for me is that work marketing and the
reason for that it takes very little
upfront cash is low overhead if you can
do it part-time it means keep your
daytime job but do this part-time and
once the business is up and running it
can generate enough income so that you
can move from the left side to the right
side of the quadrant so let me tell you
about my introduction in network
marketing because I had a very close
mind to it since I can build my own
businesses I said why do I need a
network marketing business but about 15
years ago I have a good friend his name
is Bill
and this guy is the best real estate
investor I know he has tons of assets in
here so I said bill why did you start a
network marketing business and his
simple sense was very simple he says
it's my way of helping people but more
importantly he says the reason most
people can't invest in real estate is
because they don't have a business they
don't make enough money simply because
taxes debt inflation and retirement
savings are killing them they cannot
even invest so my friend bill who was a
professional real estate entrepreneur he
says I started a network marketing
business so the people that worked with
me could start their own business and
then invest money with him so with that
I realized then that network marketing
wasn't about making money but it was
about helping people to help other
people make money so they become
financially free so the beauty of
network marketing I said like it's very
low entry point doesn't take much money
you can do it part-time and where you
profit is in most big corporations is
they spend millions sometimes billions
of dollars in advertising so Rather's
give that money to advertisers network
marketing depends on building a network
is called word of mouth like you
recommend a movie to a best friend
so really the reason I support network
marketing because it's not about selling
it's about people helping people build
assets in the asset columns becoming
business owners and then becoming
investors rather than going through all
of this here which most easy neces go
through in this section I'm going to
talk to you about a different kind of
quadrant years ago I found out there was
four kinds of people in the world you
know one type are people who must be
right these people know all the right
answers they went to school they know
everything you can't tell them anything
this is not a good business for them
because their minds are to set another
kind of person is a person who must be
comfortable you know the house could be
on fire but they're still watching TV
what's you know eating a hot dog
watching what's going on in the world
these people are toast because the world
economy is not coming back the
world economy has moved on and people
who need to be comfortable will probably
be left behind so the people who met who
need to be comfortable it probably
shouldn't talk to them cuz you only make
them uncomfortable and they're probably
not going to make the move because
number-one priority is being comfortable
another kind of person is a person who
must be liked you know they want to
please everybody this is probably not
the business for them either you know
because they want somebody else's
approval they want to be the good little
boy or girl say I did the right thing
didn't I you like me don't you
and so they don't not they'll probably
not be successful the 21st century
because they'll probably want to be like
BAE people have to be right and people
want to be comfortable alright could be
comfortable alright you're very right
yeah that's probably being like what the
business for the people of the 21st
century are people who must win and
that's where I am it one of the best
things I was taught in the Marine Corps
in at military school it's not how many
times you got knocked down it's how many
times you stand up when somebody knocks
you back what do you do oh oh you hurt
my feelings you'll probably not be
successful the world will probably pass
you by because as I said the world
economy is moved on it's not coming back
so winners will win but winning takes
sacrifice success takes sacrifice and
these are the people who will do best in
business of the 21st century so when
you're talking to people you know about
this business you have to look at them
and ask yourself is this person really
just going to be like and they'll tell
you what you want to hear or they're
going to argue with you because they
know all the right answers or they're
going to art or they don't get very
upset with you for disturbing them so
what you're looking for network
marketing business are people who want
to win people who know the economy has
moved on you'll find every race gender
age and background in network marketing
but what they really want to do is they
want to win it really is a true playing
field in the world but not for these
people these people will left behind
network marketing is what people want to
win because network marketing is a
business model of the future if you want
the government to take
interview then just keep doing what you
want to do it is possible for everyone
to win but the problem is you've got to
commit to it you've got to say this is
what I'm going to do I'm going to
dedicate five years of my life well look
at the leaders and say those are people
I want to be like those are the kinds of
people I want to hang out with that's
what you got to save yourself well as we
know there's fewer and fewer jobs you
know American corporations say they're
hiring but they're not hiring at America
that hiring overseas but more than that
is that the reason I endorse network
marketing is most people are addicted to
the paycheck and the paycheck is one of
the most sinister plots ever pulled upon
a human being if you need a paycheck
you've sold your soul you know you sold
your body your mind your spirit and your
emotions you sit there and fear of
losing your job or can I get a raise or
you know will I get promoted I mean and
then and then why would you do that
another thing about reason we endorse
network marketing we don't think of it
as a network marketing we think of it as
entrepreneur development because if you
need a paycheck this is not your
business
you know we build businesses so
sometimes when Kim and I do a deal we
may not receive a paycheck for five six
years you know and so these guys come we
go get rich quick you know and some
people do I don't know you do or not but
that is an employee get rich loser
mindset and so the thing that that work
marketing does is really kind of cure
you of the loser paycheck get-rich-quick
mentality and actually build a business
you know we build businesses but and
that's how we're rich but we didn't get
rich quick and I don't need a paycheck I
never want a paycheck so that's kind of
a revolutionary thought to most people
up there who went to school to get good
grades and get a job you know they get a
high paying job and then the higher
paying job you you pay higher taxes and
you wonder why you never get a hit
that's because you went to school to get
a job and
you've got to get away from the paycheck
and sometimes it might take 2-3 years to
get away from that and that's what
network marketing teaches people
it's an entrepreneurs mindset it's an
entrepreneurial spirit not a loser
employee I need a paycheck mentality
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what you think of this
video what you think about network
marketing if you learn from it leave in
the comments below and I'll join in the
discussion my goal with this channel is
also hit a million subscribers so
anything he did to help spread the video
share it with friends post it on Twitter
I'd really really appreciate it thank
you guys so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon